bonjour aujourd'hui on va vous parler
des banques centrales peuvent elles
sauver l'économie mondiale au jour
thomas bonjour olivier bonjour à tous
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de ses
caches émission consacrée aux banques
centrales et à leurs actions pendant
cette crise économique liée à la
pandémie de kobe 19 pour en parler nous
accueillons véronique riches florès
bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
économiste indépendante
chez rf1 search avec vous et avec
olivier on va donc passer en revue les
différentes mesures annoncées par les
banques centrales à travers le monde et
on commence par la banque centrale
européenne la bce et on a pu constater
une nette évolution dans la position
adoptée par christine lagarde
voyez plutôt ces deux déclarations de la
présidente de la bce à une semaine
d'intervalle le 12 mars
d'abord la réponse doit d'abord être
budgétaire il ne faut pas s'attendre à
ce que les banques centrales soit la
première ligne de défense déclare alors
christine lagarde
une semaine et un confinement mis en
place sur une majeure partie du
continent européen plus tard elle
affirme alors nous ferons tout ce qui
est nécessaire dans le cadre d'un autre
mandat pour aider la zone euro à
traverser cette crise car la bce est au
service des européens et ce jeudi 23
avril
christine lagarde a mis en garde les
dirigeants de l'union européenne contre
le risque d' agir trop peu trop tard
face aux conséquences économiques de la
pandémie de coronavirus selon une source
proche des discussions une première
question
véronique riches florès comment vous
analysé ce changement de discours de la
part de la présidente de la banque
centrale européenne alors eh bien de la
première raison me semble aussi de la
plus évidente c'est qu'il ya urgence
effectivement à prendre des dispositions
pour à la fois réduire le choc
économique et financier immédiat qui est
provoqué par là les mesures de
confinement liées aux os kobe 19 la
deuxième grande raison c'est que
manifestement les gouvernements
européens ne parviennent pas à se mettre
d'accord pour mener ce travail a bien
donc on retombe
dans un contexte de concots n'est bien
qui a marqué près toutes les années de
la présidence de mario draghi où
finalement il n'y a pas de commandant ou
de capitaines de navire à la tête de la
zone euro à part la banque centrale
européenne ce qui conduit effectivement
à faire tout à faire reposer la quasi
intégralité des mesures économiques et
la politique
initiative de sauvetage sur le dos d'une
banque centrale
olivier est ce que vous diriez vous
aussi peut-être que la banque centrale
européenne et donc christine lagarde ont
pris la mesure de la gravité de la
situation un peu tardivement allait
surtout totalement incompétente au poste
où elle elle était déjà incompétente au
fmi je vois pas pourquoi son transfert à
la bce l'aurait rendu compétents donc
elle change d'avis exactement comme
notre d'ailleurs comme notre président
change d'avis toutes les tous les deux
jours et donc rien ne rien ne m'étonne
ski ski ce qu'ils sont en train de faire
aujourd'hui et toutes les banques
centrales
c'est ce que je vous dis depuis très
longtemps c'est à dire le jour où il ya
un pépin c'est c'est du all in c'est à
dire
on met ce que ce qu'il faut sur la table
pour que pour empêcher sur tous les
marchés de de baisser donc ils y vont je
dirais presque à la à la japonaise c'est
c'est une japonisation des banques
centrales qui se mettre à acheter tout
et n'importe quoi la dernière
déclaration de madame lagarde c'est que
elle achètera des john bantz bon ben
voila quand on en est à ce niveau là si
vous voulez c'est que on est capable
comme comme monsieur draghi l'avait fait
en 2000 ou dedans en 2012 c'était je
ferai tout ce qu'il faut pour pour que
l'euro ne ne sont pas on est en train de
faire exactement la même chose en plus
gros parce que la situation demande qui
est plus de d'argent qu'ils soient
déversés alors si vous voulez bien on va
rentrer dans le vif du sujet on va
détailler les mesures qui ont été prises
par la banque centrale européenne ces
dernières semaines avec d'abord un
crédit aux entreprises auto de -0 75%
100 milliards d'euros de liquidités aux
banques
l'achat de 120 milliards d'obligations
le rachat de 750 milliards de dettes
publiques et privées la possibilité de
rachat de junk bond si vous en avez
parlé olivier des obligations mal notés
comme la dette grecque ou encore la
dette italienne et puis la clause du
grand-père pour les obligations en
dégradation
la banque centrale européenne a donc
annoncé un programme d'achat l'urgence
pandémique hauteur donc de 750 milliards
d'euros
l'un des aspects les plus notables de ce
programme c'est le fait que la banque
centrale européenne s'autorise désormais
à acheter les obligations de la grèce
mais aussi de s'écarter temporairement
de la clé de capital c'est à dire que la
banque centrale européenne peut
concentrer ses interventions sur un pays
en particulier
on pense notamment à l'italie véronique
riches florès est ce que vous direz que
c'est une bonne chose une bonne piste
qu'est ce que vous pensez plus
globalement de ces mesures prises par la
bce alors deux choses je pense
qu'effectivement si les politiques des
banques centrales
sont très critiquables et c'est la
critique adressée par olivier sur ce qui
se passe ces dernières années cite
également parce qu'on a laissé se
développer une sphère financière qu'ils
occupent dans nos économies et à
l'échelle mondiale d'ailleurs les
proportions comme on a quasiment
probablement jamais vu dans l'histoire
et qu'à partir de là effectivement tout
risque de correction des marchés un tant
soit peu significatif conduit à des
opérations de sauvetage proportionnelle
c'est probablement ce qui explique
l'ampleur des décisions prises
revenons sur la bce madame lagarde a
fait une énorme erreur au début la
sous-estimation des effets de la crise
étaient très très choquant d'ailleurs et
finalement elle n'a pas tenu trois jours
avant de devoir changer son fusil
d'épaulé temps les conséquences ont été
désastreuses sur les marchés financiers
et notamment sur la dette souveraine des
pays et en particulier d'italie donc on
prend des mesures alors en terme de ce
qui est ce qui me semble important
ça fait des années qu'on dit qu'il faut
qu'il faudrait se séparer de cette clé
de répartition du capital pour pouvoir
intervenir de manière beaucoup plus
efficace ce qu'on a ce qui s'est passé
effectivement c'est que les allemands et
la plupart des pays du nord mais
particulièrement les allemands ont
d'exiger effectivement le respect de
cette paix capitale pour pour contrôler
la l'équité entre guillemets des
opérations de la bce sur les marchés ce
qui a conduit à cette situation absurde
où bien évidemment le pays le plus
important étant l'allemagne
la bce a surtout acheter des obligations
de l'allemagne au point de pressuriser
le niveau des taux d'intérêt allemands
de jusqu'en territoire très fortement
négatif et est d'affaiblir
considérablement le système bancaire
allemand
donc au lieu de concentrer tous les
efforts parce qu'elle quand même
beaucoup de programmes d'intervention de
la bce au fil des années tous les
efforts sur les pays sur lesquels on
avait de vrais risques voire des risques
d'ailleurs systémique et on pense à la
grèce on pense à l'italie ce qui aurait
été beaucoup plus efficace qui
permettrait également de se présenter
comme l'institution qui intervient là où
il ya des risques là où il le faut et
qui est à 2 fait d'une force de frappe
beaucoup plus importante et bien on
dissémine des actions sur en fonction
d'une plaie capital donc au prorata des
pipes des différents pays c'était
absurde
il est important je pense que le fait de
se libérer de cette contrainte rend plus
crédible le la façon dont la bce
intervient reste à savoir et c'est loin
d'être claires mais jusqu'à présent et
semble néanmoins que à la fin de l'année
là les interventions de la bce doivent
bien néanmoins correspondre à cette
répartition du capital donc on gagne en
flexibilité au niveau des interventions
ponctuelles en pouvant potentiellement
racheté plus de dette italienne s'il ya
des tensions et si la nécessité s'en
fait ressentir que la dette allemande
mais probablement qu'à la fin de l'année
il faudra rééquilibrer tension donc
enfin on va vers quelque chose qui est
un petit peu puissant c'est me
semble-t-il mais qui est encore loin
d'être tout à fait satisfaisant olivier
une réaction sur ces mesures annoncées
par la banque centrale européenne
bah moi ce que je pense c'est que c'est
que en fait tous les verrous vont sauter
les uns après les autres on est en train
de voir ça c'est à dire le verrou de la
répartition ensuite il y avait un
deuxième verrou qui était que les
banques centrales n'agissaient pas sur
sur des djeun bomb
maintenant c'est fait vous avez vous
aurez aussi des verrous qui vont sauter
sur les marchés actions sur les au tf
exactement je vous dis c'est une
japonisation de toutes les banques
centrales à x de mario draghi en sommes
voilà on aboutira à la même chose
c'est-à-dire que ils rachèteront
directement les dettes émises par les
par les états et que vous aurez petit à
petit le même on est en train de près de
de prendre de toute façon le même le
même chemin on a des démographie en
berne
on a des taux de d'endettement par
rapport au pib qui maintenant vont
dépasser dans tous les pays largement
les 100 % quand c'est pas 150 voire
quelquefois de sens donc on est on est
en train ce japonais êtes réellement et
bat regarder ce qui se passe depuis déjà
plusieurs années au japon à chaque fois
que les taux d'intérêt remontent au
dessus de zéro va parler de jaman
vernement superbe à l'émission al
massive pour les remettre en dessous de
zéro ils achètent tous les au tf qui qui
qui sortent ils achètent des actions
directement ils achètent des indices par
on a cessé du cdu de l'open bar c'est ce
que je disais dans le monde dans mon
introduction c'est de l'open bar donc
ils mettront tout ce qu'il faudra sur la
table parce que aujourd'hui véronique
l'a dit à à l'instant vous êtes dans une
logique où les banques centrales ne sont
plus data dépendantes
c'est à dire qu'elle ne faut n
n'anticipe plus rien par rapport à
l'économie réelle mais elles sont
devenues marque est dépendante depuis
une dizaine d'années et aujourd'hui
elles doivent absolument tenir le marché
financier parce que vous avez des fonds
de pension qui sont bourrés de risques
vous avez des banques qui sont pleines
d'obligations plus ou moins pourri parce
que vous avez tout un système financier
qui est maintenant
coeur du système économique puisque tout
marche sur la dette et donc vous avez
des banques centrales qui sont devenus
complètement marque est dépendante et la
seule chose qui va les faire bouger dans
un sens ou dans un autre
sont les marchés financiers et c'est pas
autre chose c'est pas les données
économiques qu'ils ont justement les mac
je dis donc c'est on va jeter un coup
d'oeil sur la courbe du cac 40 de ces
dernières semaines il semblerait qu'il
ya eu un impact quand même des mesures
annoncées par la banque centrale
européenne mais pas seulement évidemment
véronique riches florès la question que
j'ai envie de vous poser c'est est-ce
que effectivement ces mesures ont eu un
impact concret sur les marchés en
quelques mots jusqu'où peut aller la
banque centrale européenne alors oui
pour avoir eu un impact sur les marchés
ils sont avait un impact incontestable
qui a fait rebondir les marchés des
finalement le 23 mars ans je crois que
c'est à peu près le point bas sur la
plupart des indices et c'est intéressant
parce que cette date finalement marque
que le début de la période de
confinement quasi généralisée en tout
cas croissante
c'est à dire le début du choc économique
liés à cette épidémie et et toutes les
conséquences qu'on peut en attendre sur
le plan stricto sensu économique
or ce qu'on voit c'est précisément qu'à
partir du moment où les les banques
centrales ont sorti on peut parler de
l'artillerie guerre finalement avec des
tombereaux de liquidités c'est tout ce
que énuméré également olivier des
rachats de tout on voit qu'il ya plus de
frontières est ce qu'on voit très bien
c'est que au moindre risque risque un
peu significatif alors il ya la réponse
des politiques bimonétaire donc
finalement des investisseurs ont repris
du risque est-ce que ça suffira pour
relancer véritablement la machine de
manière durable
j'en doute parce que les conséquences
économiques de la période que nous
traversons sont extrêmement négative et
que derrière cette ce regain d'optimisme
de des marchés parce qu'on parle même
pas des ans
investisseurs en réalité les
investisseurs dans la plupart des cas
sont pas véritablement optimiste mais
voilà on a des algorithmes qui
fonctionne bien pour l'instant
et donc il ya véritablement eu une
respiration à récupérer à peu près la
moitié notamment sur le marché américain
des pertes antérieures en quelques trois
semaines
donc oui c'est cette politique a eu un
effet sur les marchés est-ce qu'elle a
un effet sur l'économie
on peut considérer que si les marchés se
arrête de baisser c'est déjà un élément
négatif en moins probablement il n'en
reste pas moins qu on est face à une
situation dans laquelle c'est cette
politique est clairement insuffisante et
où on peut pas escompter que les seules
actions monétaires puisse permettre de
préparer un avenir un peu plus pur
radieux et surtout avec plus de
croissance pour sortir de cette crise on
va marquer une courte pause et juste
après on va parler des mesures prises
par la banque fédérale américaine la fed
revient dans quelques instants
de retour dans ces caches on continue
d'aborder les différentes mesures prises
par les banques centrales à travers la
planète et je vous propose maintenant de
traverser l'atlantique d'aller aux états
unis pour voir un peu les mesures qui
ont été prises par la fed avec d'abord
l'octroi de 2300 milliards de dollars de
nouveaux prêts l'assouplissement des
règles d change des devises la mise en
place de facilités de financement des
créances de court terme l'abaissement
des taux d'intérêt à 0 0%
le soutien aux marchés des prêts
étudiants du crédit à la consommation et
des prêts garantis par l'état aux
petites entreprises et l'achat
d'obligations émises par des grandes
entreprises et des prêts relais
véronique riches florès
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces mesures
de la part de la fed
à écouter la fed rachète tout ce qui est
pas sans poser de questions qui posent
une question fondamentale d'ailleurs
qu'est ciel de l'aléa moral et met donc
on abordera sans doute après la crise
dans un environnement dans un horizon
plus ou moins lointain alors pourquoi la
fed fait tels ceux ci ont d'abord on a
quand même le sentiment de plus en plus
clair que la fed n'est pas libre de ses
décisions et qu'elle obéit au doigt et à
l'oeil des injonctions de donald trump
donc la fête n'est plus indépendante
on parlait tout à l'heure de de la
financiarisation des économies s'il ya
bien une économie qui s'est hyper
financiarisé et dans laquelle les agents
ont pris 2 les investisseurs ont pris de
plus en plus de risques à tous les
niveaux c'est bien l'économie américaine
et c'est bien l'économie américaine
également qui repose pour l'essentiel
sur la santé financière notamment pour
son système de retraites et face au
système de la retraite de ces des
américains donc on a véritablement
effectivement une fan alors qui prend
toutes ces mesures qui dépassent
l'entendement qui sont extrêmement
rapides on est déjà à 10 % du produit
intérieur brut supplémentaire de danse
le mans de son bilan depuis donc en un
mois un mois et demi et qui probablement
n'aura pas de frein n'aura pas de stop
non dans cette politique donc ce sont
les les achats de tf sur des high yield
c'est la dette étudiante
on se demande même si la fed ne va pas
finir par accumuler du pétrole dans ces
souterrains pour maintenir les cours à
des niveaux qui permettrait de d'éviter
une catastrophe au niveau de la
production nationale
donc c'est vrai que c'est une politique
qui satisfait apparemment les marchés
qui pose énormément de questions quant à
la modèle américain et aux conséquences
sur de cette politique à son bien fondé
et je pense qu'effectivement au bout du
bout c'est une politique qui pose qui
devient très inquiétante sur les
perspectives du cours du dollar
à terme c'est vrai qu'il ya eu un impact
sur le dow jones également après les
annonces de la fed on le voit à l'instar
du cac 40
olivier j'ai envie de vous poser la
question est ce que l'efficacité de ces
mesures est réel pour l'économie
américaine on a souvent parlé dans cette
émission de l'impact considérable de
cette pandémie et de cette crise
économique liée à la pandémie du commis
de 19 sur l'économie américaine et sur
les salariés les travailleurs américains
c'est ce que je vous ai dit déjà je vous
ai dit que ça tombait dans un dans une
fosse croissance depuis depuis 2008 2009
c'est à dire que le vous aviez encore
plus de la moitié des américains qu'ils
n'avaient à 400 dollars devant eux
alors des gens qui n'ont pas 400 dollars
devant eux quand ils arrivent quelque
chose comme le le corps d'un virus
ils sont pas bien et qu'on les confiner
qui n'ont plus de boulot évidemment 400
$ ça va très vite donc on était dans une
dans une économie je voulais dit
plusieurs fois acquis qui finalement
n'avait pas refait gras qui n'avait pas
refait départ qui n'avait pas refait de
matelas de sécurité est en fait le le
ski à terrible c'est que ça arrive
justement sur non pas sur des économies
qui sont flambant de 2 de croissance
mais au contraire sur des économies qui
sont déjà atone avec une croissance très
faible avec un endettement très fort
avec dans tout l'est dans tous les
secteurs que ce soit les ménages sur les
entreprises que ce soient les états et
donc vous arrivez avec une crise majeure
mais pas sur des économies en haut de
cycle mais sur des économies qui
seraient plutôt en batik déjà donc
évidemment ça fait excessivement mal et
vous pouvez faire tourner la planche à
billets autant que vous voulez si vous
voulez ça ne va pas relancer les
économies on le sait maintenant je pense
qu'on en a eu les preuves pendant
pendant dix ans c'est pas la peine de
d'attendre encore deux années
supplémentaires pour pour en faire le
constat donc on sait que ça ne
fonctionne pas sur les économies et sur
l'économie réelle
en revanche ça ça ça ça booste les
marchés et là on le voit encore si vous
voulez se retrouver avec une baisse de 2
15% par rapport au plus haut qui était
déjà complètement soufflé de 15% par
rapport aux plus hauts alors qu'on est
face à une à une une crise économique
comme on en a jamais vu jamais donc
c'est inutile de comparer sagna 2008 il
ya 2001 et serra
là on est dans quelque chose qui est du
domaine de l'inconnu total on va se
ramasser des pipes trimestriel à -35
imaginez ce que c'est c'est pas rien et
donc là n'avoir qu'une baisse de 15%
parce que la fed achète tout ce qu'elle
peut ça devient un peu grotesque on
n'est plus dans un marché d'ailleurs on
est quand quand vous avez quelqu'un qui
fixe les prix ça ne s'appelle plus à un
marché donc on nous ne sommes plus dans
un régime de marchés libres nous sommes
dans un régime de fixation des prix par
les banques centrales
voilà donc que combien de temps ça va
durer et et dans combien de temps on va
revenir à une réalité un petit peu plus
objective si vous revenez à une réalité
un petit peu plus objective c'est pas à
-15 qu'on doit être c'est à -60 voilà
donc sachant qu'une une récession
normale c'est du moins 30 moins 40 sur
un marché une récession hors norme comme
on l'a eue là enfin quand on est en
train de la vivre là c'est du moins 60
qu'on doit avoir c'est pas du moins 30
ni du moins 15 un mot sur les autres
mesures qui ont été prises par d'autres
banques centrales à travers la planète
je vous les donne comme ça
pêle mêle il yad'abord l'inde qui a
abaissé son taux de référence à 3 75% le
taux de refinancement inchangé à 4 40%
et puis d'une nouvelle opération de
refinancement à long terme ciblés pour
un montant de 6 milliards d'euros
en ce qui concerne le japon on a déjà un
petit peu parlé dans cette émission
l'achat et l'effacement possible des
dettes de l'état le doublement de son
plafond annuel de rachats de fonds
négociés en bourse porté à douze mille
milliards de yens environ 101 milliards
d'euros le doublement de son objectif
annuel de rachats de fonds communs
immobilier japonais et 13,4 milliards
d'euros pour accorder des prêts sans
intérêt aux petites et moyennes
entreprises un mot enfin sur la chine la
chine qui a injecté 50 milliards de yuan
6,5 milliards d'euros sur le marché
interbancaire qui a abaissé ses taux de
référence le taux de référence à 2 2% et
qui a débloqué des extensions des
renouvellements de prêts aux entreprises
véronique riches florès est ce qu'il ya
des mesures qui ont été prises par les
banques centrales à travers la planète
qui ont attiré votre attention n'a donc
parler de l'inde du japon et de la chine
est ce qu'il ya des mesures comme ça
qu'ils ont particulièrement retenu votre
attention
ben j'ai envie de dire non pas vraiment
parce que finalement on est dans le même
moule avec des banques centrales qui
agissent selon le même modèle
1 il s'agit d'assurer la liquidité sur
les marchés alors les banques centrales
des pays émergents n'ont pas toute cette
latitude et fonctionne pas tout à fait
sur le modèle de la fed ou de la bce
mais finalement c'est bien l'objectif
d'assurer la liquidité
deuxièmement de de stimuler le crédit et
là aussi c'est assez paradoxal mais
encore une fois face à cette crise on a
déjà eu l'exemple avec la crise de 2008
qui était une crise de surendettement
la seule solution qu'on trouve
aujourd'hui c'est de renflouer par de la
dette et est donc on abaisse les taux
d'intérêt on abaisse les contraintes sur
les banques pour dans l'espoir
qu'effectivement les systèmes bancaires
finance davantage d'endettement de
crédit pour les pme
tout ceci reste du crédit et je suis
sens très sensible à ce que ce qu'a
souligné olivier on est dans cette ère
de crédit et le le plus choquant
peut-être qu'effectivement même les
émergents sont dépendants et de plus en
plus dépendants de la vigueur de la
croissance du crédit ce qui montre bien
que la croissance pour économique
spontanée structurelles on va dire est
très difficile à observer y compris dans
ces économies qui sont relativement
jeune alors si vous rajoutez à ça les
difficultés des états en particulier
c'est le cas de nombreux pays émergents
après
la chute des prix du pétrole et des
matières premières qui va sans doute
suivre c'est à dire une confiscation
immédiate des ressources de beaucoup
d'états vous avez des situations d'état
qui sont amenés à se détériorer très
rapidement donc la stratégie des banques
centrales c'est de faire baisser les
taux des taux d'intérêt les taux des
emprunts d'état donc à coup de
liquidités ou de baisse des taux
directeurs donc c'est le schéma qu'on
retrouve un petit peu partout y compris
dans des économies dans lesquelles les
devises ou la fragilité des devises
aurait pu laisser penser que ces banques
centrales hésite maintenant on voit bien
ce qu'a fait la turquie je croyais ou
avant-hier
est ce que font les unes et les autres
au brésil également où on a quand même
des devises qui sont affaiblis et qui
aurait pu perdre davantage d'ailleurs
qui vont sans doute perdre davantage à
venir dans les mois à venir et aimée qui
n'empêche absolument pas les banques
centrales d'assouplir pour faire face
aux conséquences va pour essayer de
réduire en terme financier au moins les
conséquences de cette épidémie
merci beaucoup véronique riches florès
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes économiste indépendante chez
rff serge olivier on poursuit notre
émission avec les questions cacher une
question d'abord de roanne ricardo
olivier un investissement public massif
sur une vraie transition écologique
permettrait-il de relancer une
croissance
écoutez je pense que en ce moment les
les états ou ont complètement laissé de
côté l'aspect écologique parce qu'ils
ont autre chose à faire et ils
n'arrivent déjà pas à le faire alors ne
leur demandez pas en plus de réfléchir à
la sortie un changement de modèle
radical ensuite si vous voulez moi le la
chute des prix du pétrole
me fait dire que justement avec un
pétrole aussi peu cher
je doute qu'ils aient beaucoup
d'initiatives
chercher une alternative c'est ainsi que
se conclut ce numéro de ses caches merci
à vous de l'avoir suivi vous pouvez voir
et revoir ce programme sur arte france
point tv et surtout n'hésitez pas à
poser vos questions en commentaire et
olivier tâchera d'y répondre dans nos
prochaines émissions olivier je vous
laisse le mot de la fin est bien
vivement la fin du confinement qu'on
puisse faire comme les banques centrales
open bar